[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight one of the more poignant
moments of Barack Obama's eat near
presidency came at the very end it was
January 2017 just days before Obama left
the White House and he awarded his Vice
President Joe Biden the Presidential
Medal of Freedom you may remember it
Obama spoke at great length about their
friendship their personal friendship he
praised Biden's leadership in response
Biden said he knew that no matter what
happened
Obama would always be there for him
watch it was eight and a half years ago
that I chose Joe to be my vice president
there has not been a single moment since
that time that I've doubted the wisdom
of that decision
Joe's candid honest counsel has made me
a better president and a better
commander-in-chief mr. president you
know as long as the breath into me I'll
be there for you my whole family will be
and I know I know it is reciprocal well
you didn't have to be an Obama partisan
to appreciate that moment there was
something sweet about it
was all fake though it turns out in the
end Obama is not going to be there for
Joe Biden in fact his eternal friendship
has already ended it didn't even make it
through the next presidential term
instead of helping his trusted friend
run from the presidency Obama has
refused to endorse Joe Biden according
to some reports Obama repeatedly urged
by not to run you don't have to do this
he warned Biden Obama it turns out cares
about one thing himself he's obsessed
with his political legacy every day that
Biden stays on the campaign trail he is
detracting from that legacy why weeks
ago we told you don't believe the polls
the polls say that Joe Biden is the
frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination and in fact as of today he
still is the polls tell you he's got a
very good chance of being the president
but that's not real Biden officially is
still in the lead and yet let's be
completely honest
Biden's campaign is not a real campaign
it's a zombie effort it lurches from
one blunder to another until finally
some catastrophe will put it out of its
misery even Biden's own allies want him
to stop speaking in public so often why
because when people actually see Joe
Biden they realize he's not a
distinguished elder statesman he is
sadly a fading one he thinks cory
booker's the president united states he
believes that truth outweighs the facts
he thinks he was vice president last
year during the Parkland shooting watch
I watched what happen when those kids
from Parkland came up to see me now as
vice president they went under the and
son some of you covered it so moments
like that don't make Joe Biden a bad
person but they do make his campaign
look like what it actually is a joke not
a serious play for the White House still
if Biden were offering something real a
compelling message he could get elected
anyway but he's not he's in fact a
democratic fossil he's running for
leadership of a party that sees him as
two male too pale and stale Biden is old
enough to have held public views prior
to the year 2000 eight years zero in
American politics and that makes his old
policies totally unacceptable to the
party's voters 1995 Joe Biden supported
all kinds of things current Joe Biden
would never admit to supporting a
secured border traditional marriage
drugs off the street criminals in prison
even watch this and Madam President we
have predators on our streets that
society has in fact in part because of
us neglect
created again it does not mean because
we created them that we somehow forgive
them or do not take them out of society
to protect my family and yours from them
they are beyond the pale many of those
people beyond the pale beyond the pale
now its Biden himself who's beyond the
pale the current democratic party
believes in freeing criminals protecting
criminals celebrating criminals in that
new reality Biden his suspect in fact
worse he's a relic of the past all the
energy is with the other candidates
insurgents people like was with Warren
Bernie Sanders Kamel Harris
one of these three is gonna rise above
the rest and take the nomination it will
not be Joe Biden almost everybody knows
that now and that's all bad news if
you're Barack Obama and if what you
really care about is your own cherished
legacy because Joe Biden is explicitly
running as a continuation of Barack
Obama's agenda the only problem that
agenda has been completely eclipsed by a
far more radical political agenda now
Democrats are demanding single-payer
health care which will be given for free
to illegal immigrants the ones streaming
over our open border with Mexico
candidates are advocating reparations
based on skin color the abolition
basically of America's history they want
to remake gender relations from the
ground up Obama could be seen as the one
who paved the way for all of that thanks
to his friend Joe Biden though he's
becoming the Democratic president kept
it from happening
even sooner